[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein kleines schönes
Experiment es ist kein schmexperiment
weil so wahnsinnig ich sitze auch nicht
es war einfach ein Rezept was ich mir
ausgedacht habe wo ich dachte tja ganz
cool werden denn so sollten Sie aussehen
und so sind sie geworden eine kleine bis
mittlere Katastrophe aber die sind der
Hammer und zwar sind das kleine Kürbisse
die aber mit Kürbis gar nicht zu tun
haben nämlich ein Pizzateig da kommt
eine Köfte Füllung rein das ganze ist
ein super Snack zum Mitnehmen ihr könnt
picknicken gehen ihr könnt es mit zur
Schule zur Arbeit nehmen oder einfach
auf einem fertig gedeckten Tisch mit
platzieren muffindräder vorne durch aber
ich finde es süß und ich sehe es halt im
Augenwinkel das ist echt goldig und
diese hier sind die das ist die süße
Variante die wollte ich euch einfach mit
in meiner App einfach anlegen als süß
und Lotus Creme und Nutella Creme oder
Nougat Creme was auch immer
ja aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
Zutaten für den Hefeteig
wow was sind verwirrender anfangen aber
schaut sich an für den Hefeteig verwende
ich einen Würfel Hefe einen Esslöffel
Zucker oder Rübensirup 250 Gramm warmes
Wasser 500 Gramm Mehl da habe ich ein
Dinkelmehl einen Teelöffel Salz und
etwas Olivenöl das hier im Prinzip ein
ganz normaler Pizzateig tatsächlich ihr
könnt gerne die Hefe Menge auch
reduzieren dann müsst ihr den Hefeteig
bisschen länger aufgehen lassen da sitzt
bei mir aber etwas schneller gehen soll
nehme ich jetzt den ganzen Würfel Hefe
und packe jetzt hier Wasser und
Rübensirup dazu und ich habe jetzt hier
etwas Rübensirup ihr könnt auch
kokosblütenzucker nehmen oder braunen
Zucker ich will nämlich dass der
Hefeteig ein bisschen eine dunklere
Farbe bekommt damit die Kürbisse nicht
ganz hell sind deswegen der rückensirup
wo ist er denn mein lieblingslöffel da
ist
das jetzt kurz verrühren dann kommen
Mehl Salz und das Oliven
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr hier den Hefeteig etwas
10 Minuten verkneten entweder mit der
Küchenmaschine oder per Hand und ich
kann hier auch schon etwas Hitze
dazugeben damit die Hefe nämlich schön
warm unter Teig wird schneller
[Musik]
der Hefeteig ist perfekt geknetet und
den lasse ich jetzt schön aufgehen werde
in der Zwischenzeit die Küste Füllung
machen und ihr könnt den jetzt wie
gesagt auch in süßer Variante zubereiten
dafür findet das Rezept einfach in
meiner App
denn ich müsste mich heute entscheiden
so süß oder herzhaft süß oder herzhaft
entscheiden
ja dann gibt es einen Köfte Kürbis zum
Hauptgang und Köfte Kürbis und kein
Köfte Kürbis einen süßen Kürbis zur
Nachspeise
streicht den Teig so ein bisschen mit
Olivenöl dass die Oberfläche nicht
eintrocknet ich kann ihn auch jetzt
einfach hier in der Kenwood aufgehen
lassen bzw brauche ich gleich für die
Füllung dass ich den im Ofen aufgehen
bei der Stufe
da kommt nämlich etwas Wasserdampf dann
trocknet der Teig auch nicht aus und bei
34 Grad geht optimal auf Ihr könnt ihn
aber auch einfach jetzt abdecken und bei
Raumtemperatur stehen lassen für eine
Stunde etwa bis er sich verdoppelt hat
aber bei gerstufe halbiert sich eben die
Gehzeit und in der Kenwood auch mal
deine Hitze drauf ist
[Musik]
für die Hackfleischfüllung verwende ich
500 Gramm Hackfleisch vom Rind eine rote
Spitzpaprika eine Kartoffel Zwiebel
Knoblauchzehe einen bunt Petersilie bzw
ein halbes Bund reicht schon Salz
Pfeffer Kreuzkümmel und Paprikamark ihr
könnt jetzt hier das Gemüse einfach fein
hacken oder fein reiben ich schreibe es
jetzt einfach hier in der Kenwood da
oben mit der Reibe
hier in der Küche
[Gelächter]
dafür nehme ich nämlich jetzt einfach
das Gemüse und
portionierst so das ist einfach oben
reinpasst
die Paprika entkernen und dann kommt ihr
alles in die reibescheibe
[Musik]
die reibescheibe hat ihren Dienst getan
die Zutaten kommen schon mal in die
Rührschüssel und die Petersilie die
Hacke ich jetzt fein einfach mit dem
mixmesser
[Musik]
Petersilie kommt jetzt auch hier rein
Hackfleisch und die restlichen Zutaten
und dann einfach kurz verrühren da zeige
ich euch jetzt noch was und zwar habe
ich hier ein rührelement bekommen vom
kernwood Team und da steht drin
[Musik]
jetzt hier schön verkneten
ich liebe es tatsächlich immer so auch
das ganze Werkzeug auf so ein Blech zu
legen
denn dann bleibt die Arbeitsfläche immer
schön sauber
ich finde es auch gar nicht schlimm wenn
man
das ist währenddessen
schick wollte ich sagen denn wenn ihr in
der Küche arbeitet solltet ihr immer
Ordnung halten wenn die Maschine für
euch knetet könnt ihr in der Zeit alles
sauber machen dann seid ihr schneller
fertig
ich finde es immer schön dass ich so
viel Spaß habe dabei mir macht es
einfach immer Spaß obwohl ich halt so
müde war war ich so jetzt habe ich
einfach Spaß dann habe ich jetzt hier
die fertige Hackfleischmasse und ihr
könnt natürlich selbst entscheiden wie
groß bei euch die Kürbisse werden sollen
ich nehme jetzt einfach den großen
Eisportionierer damit alles gleichmäßig
ist ihr wisst ja mein Eisportionierer
den benutze ich eigentlich nie zum
eisportionieren sondern mehr um alles
andere zu portionieren
mache ich hier diese Bällchen und lege
sie einfach schon mal hier auf ein Blech
dann ist alles bereit
das riecht so gut
ich hatte auch kurz kurz kurz kurz
überlegt Kürbis mit rein zu reiben was
auch mega cool wäre weil Kürbis
natürlich in so einem Kürbis der dann
aussieht wie ein Kürbis ganz cool passen
könnte und Kürbissen mega mega gutes
Gemüse also statt Paprika statt
Kartoffel nehmt ruhig auch gerne Kürbis
allerdings habe ich einen Mann zu Hause
der Kürbis nicht so gerne mag und ich
dachte mir jetzt da kommt für die kleine
Menge hier will ich kein Kürbis
aufschneiden auch aber
passen würde es wirklich sehr gut also
wirklich super gut
was ich aber auch generell gerne mache
wenn ich wirklich ein Hokkaido Kürbis da
habe und will zum Beispiel eine Suppe
machen aber jetzt nicht irgendwie 3
Liter Suppe dann könnt ihr auch den
Kürbis gerne reiben mache ich dann auch
hier mit den Aufsätzen oder würfeln und
einfrieren dann habt ihr immer Kürbis
auf Fahrrad
ist natürlich so ein Tipp den Murat nie
hören will aber Kürbis auch Vorrat ist
immer cool dann habt ihr einmal die
Arbeit mit entkernen schneiden raspeln
reiben würfeln und habe dann den Kürbis
immer auf Vorrat wenn ihr auch mal
kleinere Mengen zubereitet dazu
vielleicht auch so ein Chip für alle die
zu Hause alleine leben studentenköche
Singlehaushalt pärchenhaushalt
für alle die keine Küche haben
dürfen natürlich bei mir mitessen
[Musik]
ich bin 29 mit fünf Jahren Erfahrung die
Hackfleischbällchen sind ready hier habe
ich den Hefeteig da mache ich jetzt
zwölf Portionen nee 16 ich mache 16
Portion nun schauten Einteiler
das sieht sehr lecker aus
das ist auch lecker
es ist ausgelaufen da hast du recht mein
Schatz denn eigentlich hatte ich vor die
Hälfte der Hefemenge zu nehmen und dann
dachte ich so nee heute will ich dass es
schnell geht nehmt bitte die Hälfte der
Menge ich gebe sie euch auch als die
Hälfte der Menge im Block an denn wenn
wir jetzt gleich diese Kürbisse formen
dann sollten die eigentlich nicht mehr
so arg aufgehen ja du musst Hände
waschen gehen
okay also hier jetzt 16 Portionen
machst ja das nächste Mal mache ich
nicht den gleichen Fehler noch mal das
hat das gute an Fehlern ne wenn man
draußen lernt ist es okay wenn man aber
nicht so draus lernt und dann wird das
nächste Mal vielleicht wieder die
gleichen Fehler macht dann ist es doof
dass mein Kind mich die ganze Zeit ist
braucht kein Mehl dafür und kein Fett
schon so
wenn du das so in der Handinnenfläche
hier
das ist nicht so gehen Barbie Schleifen
ich habe deinen Schleimi weggeschmissen
weil dein Schleim knall rot war alles
verfärbt hat und er nicht wirklich
Schleim war sondern eher flüssig war
dann nehmt ihr alle Teigkugel
könntest du mit den Händen flach drücken
oder auch gerne mit dem ausroller aber
so ein bisschen größer
als die hackfleischkugel aber auch nicht
zu groß denn wenn jetzt das ganze zu
groß ist dann ist es immer schwierig
dass wir das zusammenzupacken und ich
gucke dann immer dass die klebrige Seite
innen ist und die mehlige Seite außen
dann hackfleischkugel rein und oben wie
so eine Buchtel einfach verschließen
und am besten heizt ihr jetzt auch schon
mal den Ofen vor denn das ganze muss
gleich schön heiß gebacken werden
so geht es nicht mehr klebrig
[Musik]
das geht so nicht ganz so gut also am
besten nicht drücken sondern gleich
ausrollen ja
guck da mache ich auch ganz wenig mehr
und dann nicht mit Druck sondern immer
schön kleine Bewegungen
nicht zu viel Mehl ja
[Musik]
wenn ihr euch ein bisschen unsicher seid
mit der Größe des Teiges ihr könnt auch
hier auf das Silikonmatte immer schön
den Kreis als Schablone nehmen
und dann wisst Ihr ganz genau das ist
schon gleichmäßig groß wird
[Musik]
hier ein bisschen Küchengarn das sind
garen was eben auch bei Hitze nicht
verbrennt sofort deswegen Küchengarn
und damit das Ganze jetzt eine
kürbisoptik bekommt ihr dürft jetzt
nicht zu eng zubinden aber damit diese
kürbisoptik bekommt lege ich den Faden
drunter und Zwirbel ihn wie ein Geschenk
und ich mache das erst so dass ich es
Viertel und dann noch mal acht lang und
dann sieht es später aus wie ein Kürbis
das teilt immer mal wieder umdrehen
schön locker lassen denn ich habe gerade
die süßen zubereitet und die sind
aufgeplatzt und ich habe zu viel Hefe
drin
[Musik]
halbe Menge reicht
findest du das schlimm dass mir das
jetzt so passiert ist ist okay oder
aber
ja weil es ist okay Fehler zu machen
wenn man dann draus lernt
wenn man noch mal den gleichen Fehler
macht das ist ein bisschen doof
aber ist auch nicht schlimm oder
vom Backen bestreiche ich die jetzt noch
ein bisschen mit Olivenöl damit zu einem
schönen Glanz bekommen
und dann am besten nicht lange rumstehen
lassen das jetzt nicht noch mal aufgehen
sondern wächst direkt in den heißen
Backofen
[Musik]
bei der Länge des Fadens orientiere ich
mich nämlich hier einfach an der
Backmatte die jetzt 60 cm und dann gehe
ich jetzt 10 cm links und rechts noch
weiter und habe dann ungefähr eine
Fadenlänge von 80 und die passt dann
perfekt
[Musik]
schauen wir mal wie die werden denn die
kleine Katastrophe zeige ich euch jetzt
gemacht
[Musik]
ein Problem ja ich sag ja
ja war ein bisschen viel Füllung aber
ich glaube es lag eher daran dass
einfach der Teig zu gut aufgeht
Luxusprobleme ich weiß aber hier wäre es
halt besser gewesen ich hätte ein
bisschen weniger Hefe rein
oder es ist halt so gewesen
hat sich da halt jetzt so ein bisschen
dann rein gebissen also reingedrückt man
muss jetzt halt den Faden raus aber wir
können ja trotzdem essen und ich mache
gleich noch mal welche die mit weniger
Hefe sind Beispiel bei so einer
flüssigen Füllung ist halt schwieriger
als mit so einer Hackfleischfüllung okay
lass mal probieren und
doch nicht so schlimm die Katastrophe
nur optisch
schmeckt gut
sind halt leckere Buchteln eigentlich in
kürbisform
okay
dann warten wir jetzt auf die herzhaften
und hoffen die beiden schön
weil diese dunkel sind
traut man sich glaube ich noch erster
nicht aber dann
weißt du warum dieser dunkel sind das
nicht weil ich sie verbrannt habe der
Teig ist dunkler
ja gut diesen dunkler gebacken das
stimmt weil ich sie bei höherer
Temperatur drin hatte
[Musik]
also die herzhaften
hervorragend die süßen leider nein auch
nach dem zweiten Versuch nicht denn die
Schokoladencreme ist einfach zu flüssig
ich glaube es wird gehen wenn man
Marzipan rein macht oder einfach
irgendwie sowas was fester bleibt und
eben nicht ausläuft wenn eben doch so
ein bisschen
Teig einreißt jedenfalls finde ich ist
der Kürbis erst dann fertig wenn er auch
oben noch so ein Stiel so ein Strom hat
und ich habe hier etwas Rosmarin aus dem
Garten riecht zum einen hervorragend und
kann natürlich hierfür verwendet werden
also hier gerne einfach das Hölzchen
reinstecken als ich bin weich die sind
ja auch echt süß aber
einfach ein bisschen festere Füllung und
guck mal wie schön eigentlich so schön
ich habe jetzt aber zu viele schon von
denen gegessen deswegen habe ich keinen
Hunger mehr aber ich probiere jetzt für
euch weil ihr seid probiere ich jetzt
noch mal so ein herzhaftes okay denn da
ist es so da ist er die Köfte Füllung
drin
hervorragend
guckt euch das mal an hier ein Köfte
Stückchen also ich finde dieses Rezept
ist herzhafte auf jeden Fall mal
ausprobieren ihr müsst ja auch keinen
Kürbis draus machen ihr könnt das ganze
auch einfach rund lassen gerne auch als
Buchteln zum Beispiel Backen habt ihr
eben kleine Brötchen aber ich finde die
kürbisoptik echt ganz süß deswegen
probiert es gerne mal aus bei der süßen
Variante muss ich sagen der Geschmack
ist Bombe der Geschmack ist der Hammer
die Optik leider nicht so da dürft ihr
euch jetzt selber überlegen ob ihr es
macht oder nicht es wird ja
funktionieren wenn man es ohne
kürbisform macht Vista also einfach eine
Buchtel machen mit Lotus und mit einer
schönen Nougat oder Schokoladencreme und
dann eben ohne den Faden drumherum dann
habt ihr die perfekten Buchteln probiert
es gern aus die Rezepte findet ihr auf
sallys-blog.de und natürlich in meiner
App viel Spaß beim Nachbacken bis zum
nächsten Mal
kann ich das wieder ausmachen
dann gehe ich in den Keller runter
ach das machen wir die Knie Test
[Musik]